veamos qué ocurre cuando oxidamos
alcoholes en la parte superior izquierda
tenemos un alcohol primario y el carbono
que está unido al grupo o h es el
carbono alfa para oxidar un alcohol
debemos de tener hidrógenos alfa debemos
tener hidrógenos unidos a ese carbono
alfa para que el mecanismo funcione en
ese mecanismo vamos a perder uno de esos
hidrógenos alfa y veremos este mecanismo
en unos minutos
entonces si quisiera oxidar
este alcohol primario le añadir algo
para oxidar oxidar emmy alcohol primario
así una forma de ver la oxidación de un
alcohol es pensar en el número de
enlaces carbono oxígeno
del lado izquierdo tenemos un enlace de
nuestro carbono alfa a este oxígeno en
el mecanismo vamos a perder un enlace
carbono hidrógeno y vamos a ganar otro
enlace carbono oxígeno por lo que se
incrementa el número de enlaces carbono
oxígeno eso por supuesto nos daría dos
enlaces
carbono oxígeno
si óxido me alcohol una vez y voy a
perder uno de esos hidrógenos por lo que
voy a seguir teniendo uno de esos
hidrógenos y mi grupo alquiló
sigue unido
evidentemente esto me dará a un grupo
funcional aldehído entonces se oxida un
alcohol primario una vez obtendrás un
aldehído
veamos ahora los estados de oxidación de
mi carbono alfa y veamos qué ocurre ahí
si quisiera asignar un estado de
oxidación a mi carbono alfa de la
izquierda de nuevo tengo que dibujar mis
electrones cada enlace consiste en dos
electrones así y necesito pensar en las
diferencias de electro negatividad el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
carbono por lo que va a tomar esos dos
electrones carbono contra carbono es un
empate por lo que cada carbono va a
quedarse con uno de esos electrones el
carbono es un poco más electro negativo
que el hidrógeno por lo tanto el carbono
gana y se queda con esos electrones
el carbono normalmente tiene 4
electrones de valencia y en este momento
está rodeado de 5 electrones entonces 4
menos 5 me va a dar un estado de
oxidación de menos 1 para mi carbono
alfa
entonces veamos que le ocurrió a ese
carbono alfa después de que lo oxidamos
del lado derecho si quisiera asignar un
estado de oxidación al que ahora es mi
carbono carbon y lico una vez más debo
pensar en las diferencias de electro
negatividad y sé que el oxígeno va a
vencer al carbono
carbono contra carbono es un empate y
carbono contra hidrógeno el carbono gana
por lo que el estado de oxidación de ese
carbono normalmente con 4 electrones de
valencia rodeado de tres esta vez 4 - 3
me va a dar más uno entonces puedo ver
que mi estado de oxidación paso de menos
1 a 1 un incremento en el estado de
oxidación es por supuesto una oxidación
si oxida es un alcohol primario una vez
obtendrás un aldehído
qué ocurre si sigues oxidando si formas
un aldehído y a veces es difícil evitar
que la mezcla de reacción se siga
oxidando entonces si oxy das un aldehído
pensarás que grupo funcional obtendrás
de nuevo una manera simple de hacerlo
sería pensar en el lado izquierdo tengo
dos enlaces carbono oxígeno existe algún
grupo funcional en el que el carbono
esté unido tres veces al oxígeno ese por
supuesto sería un ácido carboxílicos si
pienso en la estructura de un ácido
carboxílicos
puedo ver que el carbono está unido tres
veces al oxígeno
es enlaces carbono oxígeno y de este
lado tengo mi grupo alquilo muy bien
entonces si oxidamos un aldehído
obtendremos un ácido carboxílicos veamos
de nuevo el estado el estado de
oxidación del carbono carbónico una vez
más dibujaré mis electrones aquí y
pienso en la electro negatividad el
oxígeno por supuesto vence al carbono
bien
empate entre esos dos carbonos y el
oxígeno vence al carbono de nuevo
entonces en este caso
normalmente 4 electrones de valencia
ahora hay 1
4 - 1 nos da un estado de oxidación de
más
nuevamente un aumento en el estado de
oxidación significa oxidación y
oxidación aldehído obtendrás un ácido
carboxílicos
veamos ahora al alcohol secundario vamos
a bajar a nuestro alcohol secundario
y de nuevo identificamos al carbono alfa
que es el que está unido al grupo o h
necesitamos tener al menos un hidrógeno
en ese carbono alfa y tenemos uno aquí
si fuéramos a oxidar al alcohol
secundario vamos a oxidar a nuestro
alcohol secundario
nuevamente una forma simple de hacerlo
es pensar
mi carbono alfa tiene un enlace al
oxígeno entonces puedo aumentarlo a dos
enlaces y eso sería una reacción de
oxidación en el proceso voy a perder el
enlace a mi hidrógeno alfa ahora voy a
tener dos enlaces carbono oxígeno
y voy a perder el enlace que ese carbono
alfa tiene con el hidrógeno de aquí
eso deja a mis dos grupos al kilo así
ahora tengo dos grupos al kilo
y por supuesto este sería un grupo
funcional cetona entonces si oxida es un
alcohol secundario obtendrás una acetona
puedo asignar estados de oxidación
de nuevo demostremos que esto es
realmente una reacción de oxidación y
voy a dibujar los electrones en mi
carbono alfa
y pensaremos en las diferencias de
electro negatividad de nuevo oxígeno
vence al carbono carbono contra carbono
es un empate carbono contra hidrógeno
gana el carbono y carbono contra carbono
es un empate otra vez entonces
normalmente 4 electrones de valencia en
este ejemplo está rodeado de 4 entonces
4 menos
nos da un estado de oxidación de 0 para
nuestro alcohol secundario y cuando el
óxido voy a obtener está cetona de aquí
del lado derecho veamos ahora al estado
de oxidación de la acetona que antes era
el carbono alfa de la izquierda que es
ahora nuestro carbono carbónico de nuevo
dibujamos
los electrones
y pensamos en diferencias de electro
negatividad el oxígeno va a vencer al
carbono entonces vamos así carbono
contra carbono es un empate carbono
contra carbono es un empate
de nuevo normalmente es 4
- 2
esta vez alrededor de ese carbono nos da
un estado de oxidación de más 2
entonces para ir de un alcohol
secundario a una acetona vemos que hay
un incremento en el estado de oxidación
por lo que esta es definitivamente una
reacción de oxidación
veamos ahora un alcohol terciario aquí
está mi alcohol terciario
y cuando encuentro mi carbono alfa veo
que esta vez no hay hidrógenos unidos a
mi carbono alfa de acuerdo con el
mecanismo que veremos en un minuto no
hay manera de oxidar
este alcohol terciario bajo condiciones
normales
entonces si intentáramos oxidar este
alcohol diríamos que no hay reacción
aquí ya que nos falta un hidrógeno alfa
echemos un vistazo al mecanismo y veamos
por qué necesitamos tener un hidrógeno
alfa en nuestro carbono alfa si
comenzará mi mecanismo con un alcohol
recuerden que este debe ser un alcohol
primario o secundario para que la
oxidación se lleve a cabo entonces voy a
dibujar mi alcohol aquí de nuevo debe de
ser primario o
secundario y cuando tenemos un alcohol
primario o secundario va a reaccionar
con ácido crómico
está
es la estructura de los ácidos crónicos
lo voy a simplificar aquí no me
preocuparé mucho por mis pares de
electrones disponibles el ácido crómico
puede provenir de varios reactivos
probablemente el reactivo más común sea
di cromato de sodio que es
r2
ácido sulfúrico h2s
y agua
y todo esto junto es generalmente
llamado reactivo de joux
es una mezcla entre ti cromato de sodio
ácido sulfúrico y agua y el llamado
d
young
y eso se mezcla y produce ácido crómico
en solución bien otra manera de hacerlo
sería empezar con trióxido de cromo
podríamos usar un reactivo diferente qué
consiste
r
trióxido de cromo
h 3
más
sé
todo na
y eso también produciría ácido crómico
en solución cualquiera de estos puede
ser usado
el primer paso del mecanismo es similar
a la formación de ésteres de nitrato que
vimos en el vídeo anterior entonces este
va a ser una reacción de equilibrio o
reacción reversible y si recuerdan en la
forma de ésteres de nitrato hay un
mecanismo similar para la formación de
todos los ésteres inorgánicos vamos a
perder vamos a perder este hidrógeno
este o los cuales van a producir agua
podemos juntar esas dos moléculas y
obtendríamos este
como producto inicial como producto
inicial vamos a tener el resultado final
de poner ese oxígeno unido a un átomo de
cromo como este entonces este es un
esther de cromo intermedio
esto es lo que obtendríamos en el
siguiente paso del mecanismo necesitamos
algo que fija como base y el agua va a
hacer eso entonces vamos a tener agua
aquí dos pares de electrones disponibles
uno de esos pares va a funcionar como
base y va a tomar ese protón alfa
recuerden que este es nuestro hidrógeno
alfa en este carbono y de este lado
vamos a tomar solo el protón solo el
núcleo de ese átomo de hidrógeno y
entonces este par de electrones de aquí
tomarán ese protón eso hará que el
electrón que tenía el hidrógeno se vaya
atrás y estos dos electrones van a
moverse hacia acá para incrementar el
número de enlaces carbono oxígeno
y al mismo tiempo eso va a llevar a
estos electrones de este enlace hacia el
cromo dibujemos los productos resultados
de esta reacción veamos dónde hay
espacio
aquí
entonces perderemos ese hidrógeno alfa y
ahora nuestro carbono
sigue unido a otras dos cosas perdimos
ese hidrógeno alfa y ahora está
doblemente enlazado al oxígeno
ese sería el mecanismo
pasamos de un enlace carbono oxígeno en
nuestro alcohol primario o secundario y
ahora lo hemos aumentado a dos enlaces
carbono oxígeno los otros productos los
otros productos de la reacción son h 3 o
más vamos a dibujar h
más cuando el agua se lleva a ese protón
formaríamos h
r
- como otro producto
ahora si el carbono alfa es el que está
siendo oxidado si este carbono es
oxidado a este carbono es el mismo
carbono pero este carbono está siendo
oxidado algo debe de estar siendo
reducido porque es una reacción redox si
oxida es algo
otra cosa es reducida y esa otra cosa es
el cromo si asignaron los estados de
oxidación al cromo en el di cromato de
sodio de aquí en esta molécula de aquí
el cromo tiene un estado de oxidación de
más cuando vemos nuestros productos y
encontramos al cromo en nuestros
productos si asignamos un estado de
oxidación a este cromo obtendríamos 4
más
r 4 más
y hay otra reacción que termina
convirtiendo al cromo de 4 más
cromo
finalmente podemos ver que empezamos con
6 más de este lado y terminamos con un 3
más aquí
eso es una reducción en el estado de
oxidación por lo que el cromo está
siendo reducido entonces ese carbono
alfa está siendo oxidado y el cromo está
siendo reducido en esta reacción redox
en el siguiente vídeo
veremos varios ejemplos que involucran
alcoholes primarios y secundarios